you know this guy Milo foran yeah he's a
big director so he he saw me on Saturday
Night Live so he got the idea I was
smart everybody always thought that I'm
reading the news and [__] like that she
come to her we go out we eat no boo and
and [__] right and so I go with them so
it's me him and two guys from for two
foreigners right and so these guys know
everything you know and so they're like
ah what about the situation in the
Balkans or something like that yeah
you're the newsman and I just kind of
play along like by repeating what they
had said three sentences ago and uh so
anyways he goes I put you in the movie
man I need the guy to and he was going
to give me a big part right so I was
like no no no don't do that like I can't
act and he's like don't have to worry
about it I go seriously Milos I don't
want you to give me a big part so he
give what do you want I go just you know
give me a small part that'd be cool so
he made me a reporter right in this in
this people versus Larry Flint right
yeah I played one of the people right so
originally you I think sounds like you
were about to be Larry Flint right oh my
God Larry Flynn so we do the movie right
and uh uh and I'm a reporter you know so
he goes you know you drive up and get
out of the car and run in I go well I
can't drive he goes oh so he goes okay a
cab will drive you so it doesn't make
sense like a reporter is in a cab so we
do the scene it's me and Woody harelson
yeah so then anyways Woody Harrelson's
really and [__] actors man when
they're really good it's like something
different you know cuz I'm just waiting
for the other [__] to stop talking and
hope God I remember my you're not even
paying attention no I'm just hoping to
remember my words so anyways uh [__]
what's his name Woody harelson asked me
if I want a beer you know he goes you
want a beer I go no that's cool I don't
I don't drink you know he goes you don't
want a beer I go no I don't drink but
thanks man and then I go uh you drink
like uh I thought you just smoke weed
and all that [__] and then uh all of a
sudden me former goes cut what the [__]
is going on like we were in the movie
you didn't know know you thought he
talking to you CU he was looking at me
and talking like a a regular person
there was nothing fake about it you got
caught up in the
movie